if your co parent immediately moved a new mommy in
and really try to drill it home to the kids to try to replace you
let me encourage you
it really doesn't matter how little the child is
you are their mother
they were created inside of you
there is a natural bond that that child has with you
they are never gonna see somebody else as Mama
think of all the stories of people looking for their natural birth mother
all these kids that got adopted
it was beautiful story still
but they still wanna try to find out who was their birth mother
there is a connection between a mother and their child that cannot be broken
here's another thing that will happen
the kid might slip up and either call you this other woman's name or you might
uh here through the Grapevine that your child is calling the other person mom
either whether they slipped up or they're being taught to do that
still doesn't matter
it doesn't fucking matter
I can call an elephant a raccoon
it's not gonna make the elephant a fucking raccoon
your kid could call their fucking cup mom
it's not gonna make it mom
it's the same fucking thing
just because someone's teaching them or they're a little kid and
you know the back and forth and all around
sometimes you call your fucking teacher mom
you know what I mean
you can't let those tiny little things
ever try to convince you that your motherhood is less than what it truly is
and it is an undying connection between you and your child
that is your child
think of your mother
whether you have a good relationship or not
we always yearn for our mother
that's why it hurts so bad sometimes
you know so just remember that your baby loves you
and it doesn't
does not fucking matter who comes in their life